De zorra se Han dicho cosas superoriginales
tanto buenas como malas.
¿Creéis que hay alguna manera de
conseguir que la gente
que no se ha molestado en entender el
el mensaje lo entienda
y que es lo más original que habéis leído
de todas esas cosas que se ha dicho?
A ver yo creo que que
eh hay que respetar
a la gente que no entiende el mensaje
porque por mucho que quieras
eh explicar a veces algo
eh no hay que explicar los hechos,
son los que son y ya está,
entonces para mí eh
hay gente que ya lo está entendiendo
que al principio es era 1 poco reacia
al mensaje y a la canción
por a lo mejor el el estilo musical no te gusta
porque al que le gusta el rock duro
no le VA a gustar el sin pop,
entonces yo creo que poco a poco
pues de tanto escucharla igual lo entiende
y luego pues algo curioso que nos haya,
hay muchas cosas bonitas que nos Han dicho eh
sí la verdad que eh
nos quedamos con el otro día
estando
cuando íbamos en en el taxi y en en el transfer y
y el Chico que lo llevaba
nos dijo si le podíamos hacer 1 vídeo para
para 1 amigo,
que su Madre estaba estaba enferma de de cáncer y que
y que la canción le había ayudado le había ayudado,
no le había devuelto la sonrisa y eso nos pareció
nos pareció ¿Tan grande eso no? Que que 1 canción eh
consiga eso en 1 persona.
¿Ves? ¿Esa es la magia de de la música no?
¿Eh? Esa como Buena y como mala. A mí me lo del je,
claro, las recibe Ella,
a mí me Han llamado señor mayor,
pero bueno, es 1 cosa que tampoco es que no sea real,
ya tengo 1 edad,
Barbie de celiaticón,
Barbie gato escayolado también, eso moló mucho,
pero pero nos tomamos
con mucho sentido del humor estas críticas,
porque tampoco son o ofensivas,
de todo se aprende, yo creo que que también
eh, ¿cuando recibes eso tanto bueno como malo eh?
1 se tiene que hacer autocrítica
y decir, pues bueno,
¿yo a veces también he criticado cosas no?
Entonces es cuando te das cuenta